this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck this podcast
has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
ryan nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists we're here today with our
returning champion yes
dr nicole lapara is here and on the
occasion of her new book how to do
the work i'll hold this up if you're
watching this on youtube
nicole thanks for being here today
joshua ryan thank you for having me back
i'll tell you what uh we're lucky our
blurb made the back of the book
yeah man and so i thought i would start
with this because during this minimal
episode i want to talk about healing
today since i think that is a central
theme of
the book there are obviously other
components i want to talk about but on
the maximal episode
i thought we would really dive into
understanding
trauma and the ego and also setting
boundaries maybe getting into
some boundary setting as well and cover
that uh what is discussed in the book
here but we'll start with this
blurb on the back of the book it says on
the surface dr lapera's book appears to
be a how-to
manual but at its fundament it's a book
about
understanding the self for it is only
when we deeply understand
that we're able to heal yeah and
the reason this book yes it is called
how to do the work
but it's not necessarily a how-to manual
in that sense and i love that because
ryan and i often
use the trojan horse of minimalism to
discuss a whole bunch of other things
right
and for you it's like of course people
uh kapil gupta says we are smitten with
prescriptions we always want to know the
how
to side of things and you have that in
here for sure you talk about
some steps that people can take to heal
to do the work right
but also it's i think fundamentally it's
about understanding it's not just about
aimlessly doing
action and so what prompted you to write
this book
and and help people with that
understanding what prompted me to write
the book actually was
coming from the depths of disempowerment
for myself as a human
and and for my clients so i was several
years into a private practice
um i was working in the modality i
learned providing talk therapy
on the other side of things as a human
i'm someone as long as i can remember
i've struggled with anxiety really hit
its peak in the 20s where i met my first
panic attack which for those of us who
know and have experienced those are
quite a nightmare
so i've been on both sides in the room
of on the couch if you will and the
practitioner
and what i came to see not only evidence
in my own life but
in many of my clients week after week
year after year was
stuckness incredible amounts it's
interesting you kind of
brought this idea this concept of
knowing and doing
and i think a lot about that because
what i started to see
and experience myself was increasing
amounts of knowing of insight
beautiful sessions with humans who were
able to piece together
patterns that weren't working habits
that they want to break even
game planning for how to do things
differently in a future time
yet what i continue to find is stuckness
we kept repeating those patterns we
couldn't build the bridge
if you will from knowing better to doing
differently in life so
for me it was curiosity at first me
trying to understand
myself if you will as a human a bit
better understand why
despite having tools despite being in
treatment
i still wasn't able to get better then
of course i wasn't able to
help my clients as well so through that
you know curious exploration i
was met with a lot of new research or
new to me
at the time and really began to
understand the need to evolve the field
in a much more holistic direction and to
work not only with the mind as i had
been doing
but really to include the body and a lot
of the ways we are dysregulated
that are keeping us stuck as i continue
to see week after week
let's talk about some of those ways that
we're stuck i thought maybe since ours
is a listener driven show let's dive
into some questions
ryan you want to read patty's question
to to kick us off here
sure peggy writes in how do you start on
a path to healing
and commit to it when your motivation is
almost
nil so i think this is the the how-to
thing
which again smitten with prescriptions
we all want to know how to do
something but also it does start with
that knowledge or the understanding that
there is a problem right
well i think what's important to hear
for patty and other listeners who have a
similar question understand
is that as humans we're not actually
wired to change
we have a very distinct drive to stay in
those familiar
patterns so i say that our subconscious
really is based
on the principle of keeping us safe it's
very safety driven and unfortunately
according to our subconscious
safety is the familiar the path i've
been down before
this is where it's very counterintuitive
it's not because for many of us and
listeners are probably sitting here well
the paths i've been down have only
carried negative consequences however
according to my subconscious that's much
safer than the unknown
than the path i have yet to explore so
we become
locked again reliving habits and
patterns which don't serve us
and the reason why i'm answering in this
way to patty's question
is because so many of us do wait for
motivation to change we wait to be
inspired we wait to
you know one day hit the ground running
and want to do all of these things
differently and when we don't when we're
inevitably
as we often are met with resistance
either the million thoughts of why we
shouldn't why today's not the right day
to do all of these new things some of us
it's a feeling
we feel agitated we feel uncomfortable
we just don't feel like ourself
so before you know it we're right back
living into those familiar patterns so
to patty to everyone out there who's
waiting to want to change or to feel
inspired in a deep way or to even
have the energy to do it i'm here to
suggest that that
might not be the case it's how do we
create action when we don't have the
motivation yet
i think a piece of it too with uh you
know us getting stuck in these patterns
it's it
also has to do with uh reserving our
energy too right
like your body is you know for all
intents and purposes we are all
really really lazy beings like our
bodies want to do things the easiest way
but um i'll tell you one thing that
helped me
with just different changes that i
wanted to make in my life when i had no
motivation or even inspiration it was
you know almost accepting
like with working out i would accept the
fact that it might be really bad workout
i may not do it properly i may not have
the right form
um you know whatever it is i'm gonna
fail in some way
that used to prevent me from taking
action because i was worried about not
doing it correctly
but then when i've realized if i can
embrace that failure it's like anything
else you practice it enough
and then you start to get good at it and
then you know that kind of
that will motivate you more and more as
you start to see some improvement so i
think you know
patty needs to really be prepared to
fail you know and that's okay but taking
action is really the important part here
and i think maybe reframing that failure
is what you've been really good at ryan
is is understanding that you know i
teach a writing class how to write
better and in there the thing i talk
about is the words
are never as perfect on the page as they
are on your head
right and you have experiences i mean in
writing a book it's like
of course the concepts they're all it's
always perfect before you've taken any
action at all
but of course then it's utterly
imperfect because there's nothing there
it's not what you're even trying to do
anyway right and so there's a sort of
the fear
of taking action because it's never
going to be as perfect as
as you wanted to be is that fair
absolutely and i i can resonate i was
smiling ryan you're saying that i'm
someone who unless i know i'm going to
win
i historically don't like to play i'm
glad i'm not the only that's just the
truth of the matter and so very much i
would have those rehearsals come to the
conclusion that maybe i wasn't going to
be perfect at this thing and
at the first sign of that imperfection i
very much was the person
who would want to throw in the towel you
also brought up a really important
physiological aspect of this
it is down to our calories our brain
already as an organ needs the most of
our calories that we
intake in any given day so our from a
caloric standpoint
when we're coasting in that autopilot
we're actually conserving
our resources in a very real way so
physiologically we are very lazy animals
because we prefer to spend our attention
elsewhere
and to spend again our calories
elsewhere so if we can coast as our
brain prefers to do
we then free up our resources so that is
why
as we begin to create change i'll often
hear
and experience exhaustion it's
incredibly tiring
to fire up my brain in a new way to be
consciously present to not be coasting
on that
autopilot yeah that in itself is just a
hard obstacle for anyone
i really like the writing uh that you
brought up the writing class
because your big thing millie is to get
that crappy first draft out of the way
yeah and it is sfd
and it is it's it's it's a that first
draft is always going to be crappy have
you ever
like written you know 10 000 words and
not change one of those words
right never right and the reason being
is
in fact i'm more of like a nine draft
kind of person
i i realized that recently with our our
new book that's coming out a lot of
people use things
i finally thought i had it because this
is our fifth book and
fourth together and i was like okay
finally have this it's
one done maybe a second draft and by the
time okay
fourth or fifth draft and no of course
it was still
nine drafts by the end of it and
and i realized like oh this is just part
of
the process i could look at i could
reframe it as all those eight failures
well no it was eight steps to get to
where i wanted to be
that's all it was it took a little bit
longer the path was more circuitous
but of course isn't that where all the
exploration is anyway
yeah yeah i really feel like if if
people can
get comfortable with the process rather
than
focusing on the results the results will
come
but that process is really that's the
piece
that if you can get comfortable with
then yeah the results will follow i
think it's tricky though right
yeah because we also want to have a
destination in mind
um and i'd love to hear your thoughts on
this because you know when
i left my apartment this morning and i
walked in here to the studio
yes i could say it's all about the
journey but i also had a destination in
my i was walking
here specifically right and i could have
been wherever i end up i end up well
that would also screw me up as well
so understanding where we're going to go
yeah and the journey
is also i think it's almost like they're
equally important in a way
what are your thoughts on that i think
they are equally important and i think
choice really becomes
the the important component here right
making a choice
when we're paying attention to our
future goal and when we're grounding
ourselves in the moment and creating
space for both
having the moments whether it's you know
planning or journaling or however we
prioritize what our goals are
some of us even like to break them down
right 10-year goals five-year goals a
year goals
having the long view of future though
then
in the moment grounding ourself in the
moment okay what step can i take now how
present can i be to what's happening
here and now
that will build me to that place so it's
kind of being able to use that pivot
and i'll speak as someone who only
really always had my eyes on
that hypothetical doneness place that
i've been endlessly searching for where
all of my boxes are checked and
i can relax you're a completist just
like ryan and i are
a lot of us are i think a lot of us
culturally i think we got a lot of
messaging from a very early age
of over emphasis on doing even doing in
terms of our thoughts our thinking mind
this idea of
just sitting you know in peace is is not
productive in some way so some of us
even if we're not physically
doing around our environments we're
mentally doing all the time
for a lot of us that is a future based
thought process and
yes we are humans we are gifted with
that ability
i mean one of the main separations of us
and animals
is that ability to view our past to
troubleshoot what maybe
didn't work to even plan for a future
that's different
yet i think a lot of us fall into that
trap of too much
doing too much seeking so how do i find
that space where i have my eyes on a
goal
and i can still be grounded in the
present to get me to that goal
and that goal or arrival or whatever we
want to call it
can either be empowering or
disempowering depending on what it is
like when i
walked into the studio this morning if
the walk was 1700 miles
i would have just thrown my hands up in
the air and say oh look i this is
unrealistic right but no it's whatever
it is a mile and a half two miles and
it's like oh
i can do that because it then it is okay
what do i need to do in this moment
in order to arrive we have another
question here from
lottie in washington dc do you have any
advice
if you're interested in a minimalist
lifestyle but your significant other is
not
personally clutter stresses me out and
that's one of our biggest
fighting points is i prefer a clean and
clutter-free house and he prefers to
hang on to things
so nicole if i were to rephrase this
question in a way that's applicable to
everyone because a lot of people listen
to this podcast they're obviously
listening for the whole minimalism
aspect and the clutter and we think it
starts with the stuff
our material possessions are a physical
manifestation of what's going on inside
us quite often
there's a lot of internal clutter that
we're dealing with and so i want to talk
to you about some of that
internal clutter so if i rephrase the
question it's how do i work with someone
i love
to adjust our lifestyle preferences so i
can attain
and maintain mental peace
and so there that's really what we're
talking about here is there's a lack of
peace
because there is some there's some
tension in the household right
it doesn't it's not always around stuff
it can be around any number of things
yes absolutely i get this question too a
lot joshua in the context of
someone being inspired to start a
healing journey and the similar then
question that follows is what do i do if
my partner
seems resistant isn't on board is doing
their own thing or whatever
version of that is so now you sometimes
hear it manifested as
how do i force my partner to have my
same exact ideals so
the first response to this is exploring
what we really
mean because a lot of us that is our
intention is how do i create change but
really
how do i make someone else change how do
i and as someone lottie if that is was
that her name
so lottie i will say i'm the first
person to resonate with your experience
i am
so energetically sensitive my space in
my apartment
really does affect me and my partner so
happens to sound like your partner who
seems a little less sensitive to the
environment and therefore when there are
items around
i tend to be the one that falls in feels
agitated about that so i'm speaking from
very much resonance
and i know how much our spaces can
affect us
however i also understand what our
intention sometimes is and sometimes
it's
i want my partner to clean up to live in
an environment that reflects my
preferences so how do i find that middle
ground
[Music]
so it is finding that middle ground
finding the spaces finding the
activities finding
how you can clear up your mess whether
it's
figuratively in the space maybe having
designated areas
for perhaps your life or your living or
areas where your partner can put their
stuff
keeping it out of your space so you can
be practical
in terms of localizing things like of
that nature i think that can be really
helpful
but i think what we really want to
explore is what do we mean
can we find a middle ground it often
isn't exactly the way
we envisioned we want it um it really is
finding that negotiation and sometimes
it can be
sifting out space here's where your
stuff can live where i can have my
moment of peace
and understanding that we can't fully
change someone completely
yeah if we would like to one of the
things that ryan and i often say is you
can't change the people around you but
you can change the people around you
meaning of course you can't force
someone to change but you can also
surround yourself with
loving supportive people who have
similar preferences as you now
what i'm not suggesting to lottie here
is well then you know
dump the bastard and move on because
he's you know full of clutter and that's
the wrong way to live
i just want you to understand that that
there is a price of admission
in any relationship and if i were to
you know if my wife decided hey i've you
know i've decided to become a maximalist
and uh okay well then now all of a
sudden i have a decision to make i
either
because i can't change you and nor would
i want to adjust your preferences
to to map onto mine that's that's
dragging someone in your
direction and of course i don't want to
drag her in my direction
if you get dragged that's not loving at
all that's
clinging attachment it's the opposite of
love and so
uh the price of a mission would be okay
can i tolerate this can i
respect and appreciate this or is this
not a price i'm willing to pay and if
it's not a price to one i'm willing to
pay
then i need to be willing to have that
difficult conversation as well
yeah i hear lottie asking us how do i
get my partner to
support me how do i get my partner to
show me respect
and the best way to do that lottie is if
you go out of your way to support your
partner
and show your partner respect like
they're going to give that back to you
um what she did say in the question was
is how they fight and it takes two
people to fight
it's not just one person yes so you know
lottie if you catch yourself
fighting um just show your partner that
you love and respect him by
taking a step back and de-escalating but
if you're escalating it
um and fighting that's certainly not
going to get anywhere
yeah we have a question here from bonnie
you want to read that one ryan yes
i think this one's from facebook how do
you forgive others and yourself
and move forward when a loved one passes
suddenly and you feel
you haven't had a chance to tell them
everything you needed to
and how do you forgive others that you
feel treated that person terribly in
life
and let go of the anger toward them this
nicole this one is fascinating to me
because forgiving others
and yourself and move on when a loved
one passes suddenly
you know my mom didn't pass suddenly but
she died over a
eight month period she had stage four
cancer and
um you know i think we sort of came to a
dayton at the end but yeah there are
certain there are regrets there so maybe
we can talk about that in respect to
bonnie's question here yeah forgiveness
and i think regret go hand in hand a lot
um
i think the first thing to explore is
what what does forgiveness mean
what is the definition of that i think
we all have different definitions
of what forgiveness is my definition of
forgiveness
has to do a lot with acceptance
accepting what was
doesn't mean we have to feel positive
about what was
we can still retain how we felt about
what had happened
what goes into acceptance for me and can
be really helpful in answering this
question
is awareness of the other human and
their possible
limitations around their own
conditioning i talk a lot about
intergenerational patterns my
understanding is that we are very much
limited by the people who came before us
by the tools they had by the resources
they had by what they were able
to model for us and experience with us
in often relationship with us
and the truth of the matter for most of
us is we were raised with
people with caregivers that had their
own limitations so for me when i explore
the concept of forgiveness
it means making space for that awareness
that empathy
that understanding that this thing might
have hurt me in my past whatever he or
she did or didn't do
i can feel hurt by that and over time
perhaps i can expand to understand what
caused that what their own past was like
and again that doesn't necessarily mean
i end up feeling positively and it
doesn't even mean of course this isn't
in the context of this question if the
person we're living that also doesn't
mean i carry on
a relationship with this person so
getting clear
on what forgiveness is for each of us
because again i think we
get confused at what we mean and some of
us believe that forgiveness means we
have to just be over it
entirely and there's many ways we're not
over it we can still feel about it
we can still accept the limitations and
still choose again to modify
relationships so the answer is some
version of that
for a lot of us it's an internal process
of forgiving
and again some of it does begin with us
forgiving ourselves first
us looking at perhaps the role we played
with the human that we lost or whatever
is that we're looking for forgiveness
around a lot of us have to
grant ourselves that first and i say
that knowing a lot of us are very
critical of ourselves and we don't
actually let ourselves off the hook
that some of us can do so much more
easily for another so
a lot of times self and other
forgiveness really do go hand in hand
totally i'm reminded of uh matt
nathanson lying i'd
i would kill anyone who treats you as
bad as i do
yeah and i i often feel that about
myself the way if
if someone was as critical of me as i am
of me
i would not spend an hour around that
person yeah
and yet i have to spend 24 hours with
this person
every single day now ryan the second
part of this question had to do with
with anger right letting go of anger and
i think maybe you could also say
letting go of sadness that's part of the
pattern as well right
yeah i mean i like i like what uh you
were saying nicole about acceptance
because the way he described it it
wasn't good or bad
it just is and i think if someone can
work towards
that piece of it and i think they get
there through what you talked about
through a little bit of
uh empathy or maybe compassion um
maybe think of rob bell i don't know if
you've ever heard of rob bell he's he's
uh
awesome awesome uh i don't know
philosopher i'll call him he used to be
a preacher but anyway he has this thing
where he talks about
you know everyone around you is fighting
their own battle
everyone so if you could you know look
at that person that you're angry at
and instead of trying to feel positive
about them you could at least
stop feeling so negative about them if
you maybe
accept the fact that they're fighting
their own battle and
you may not even know the battle that
they're fighting so trying to
again accept which is neither good or
bad um i think that's a huge piece of
that
the one thing i'll say too about um
yourself and feeling like you didn't say
everything you needed to say
and you know now now uh bonnie is
beating herself up
like i think about like so with josh and
i let's say that you were a complete
[ __ ] to me i mean you are a complete
[ __ ] dude
right so let's say you were a complete
[ __ ] to me and i died right and i'm
up in heaven and i'm watching
you you know mourn or whatever and you
start to beat yourself up
over um being an a-hole like what i
would really wish for josh is two things
one be kind to yourself like that's the
best thing
that i think bonnie can do is first like
like you said josh like be kind to
yourself don't treat yourself poorly
and then the second thing is i would
love to see josh
start to maybe other people that he's
being
an a-hole with maybe he reverses that
and he starts to
uh use the time that he has left to
change the behaviors because i think
about that with
like with my wife for example who is
alive
i i uh um but i can you know i can still
see with her where there are things that
i've done that have hurt her
and whether it was um an argument or you
know whatever like i'm
you know i'd love to sit here and say
i'm perfect but i'm not and i used to
beat myself up for that but kind of what
i tell myself is like look
you still have a long relationship with
with mariah
so use that time and do what you wish
you would have done
you know up to that point yeah so um
yeah so acting different to others even
though you know maybe that loved one has
passed away you can still use
that as an example or as a lesson to
help you treat others differently moving
forward and spend the time and say the
things that you need to say
to those and one other rob bell-ism
for you he talks about echoing what
nicole just said
sometimes the best way to love someone
is from a distance yeah
and so because you've forgiven someone
as you say it doesn't and if they're
still
around it doesn't mean that we have to
continue to have the same relationship
with them in fact we don't have to have
any
close relationship with them at all
especially if it's a toxic relationship
they may be toxic you may be toxic it
could just be that
it's two perfectly non-toxic people and
the chemical reaction of them together
causes some sort of chemical or toxic
explosion
and and it's just it doesn't go together
very well but before we wrap up this
question
can we talk to bonnie about letting go
of anger
yeah letting go of anger anger comes up
a lot and is very understandable
something i wanted to just add on to
this piece that applies here too
a lot of times we're having a feeling
because we're assigning a meaning a very
personalized meaning
someone didn't love me enough so they
didn't show up in this way
so whether again we're talking about
anger or this whole conversation around
forgiveness
the reason why i think about you know
lineages
and and um limitations that are passed
on to us
is because it often isn't personal even
when i'm having a reaction that could be
very
like i am also not perfect i say things
i don't mean i do things i don't mean
when i'm having an emotional reaction to
something
in that moment it is the far it's not
about the person that i'm typically
projecting on who happens to be my loved
ones my partner who i'm screaming at or
right ranting about or you know two in
that moment
it's really not about her in the moment
it's about
some older pain that's been unearthed a
lot of times same thing applies with
anger when we're feeling
angry yeah it might be projected
triggered
activated by something that someone did
though i think for many of us if we
really dive into it and understand
there's something deeper going on for
anger it's typically an unmet need
that's gone unmet for quite some time
yeah so again de-personalizing
um being able to pull back for some of
us that creates the space to have
another feeling
to have anger or grief and compassion or
whatever it might be
for others it's learning how to navigate
our emotions
any emotion entirely because what a lot
of us do and i talk about it in the book
a lot of us make emotions mental events
i mean
some of us make them mental matinees
lifetime events like that go on for
years
we don't allow emotions to just live in
our body
as they do emotions are energy they're
hormonal shifts and changes they
end however what a lot of us are doing
especially with
anger we have a reaction of anger
and then we bring it up to our mind and
we begin to stew or ruminy about what
made us angry whether it happened now or
25 years ago and then we live that
scenario on in our
continuing to expand then the duration
of anger or insert really any feeling
so when we're learning to navigate as
many of us need to do into adulthood
we need to cultivate emotional
resilience cultivate the ability
to navigate our emotions i know i had
zero ability i lived
so disconnected from any of my emotions
that
dropping into my body and being able to
be with my feelings as physiological
events was a practice
in and of itself and if we can break
that habit of telling ourselves stories
about our emotions and essentially
living in them many of us can give
ourselves the opportunity to have a
feeling
tolerate it and then allow it to release
yes
the first step in letting go is to stop
clinging
you can tweet that podcast sean but i i
think the
the the the understanding maybe anthony
demelo
would say that if you
you're not an angry person you're not an
angry person it's anger appears
and i think we have a hard time
uncoupling
the anger from the individual right
meaning
i am angry no no i'm not angry anger has
arisen
within me and once i've uncoupled that
i'm able to not cling to that anymore
i'm able to see that for what is yes
anger has appeared and it appears as
though it is
inextricable for me but i know it's not
because three minutes ago
i wasn't angry or three days ago or
whatever it is
i wasn't angry and so understanding that
allows us to drop it not prescriptively
here are the three steps to let go of
your anger
but in a sense that once i understand
the anger i will
it's like a snake crawling on me i don't
need the three-step manual to fling it
off of me as soon as it crawls onto me
i simply will notice the snake and
immediately
will drop it let it you know get it off
of me
and i don't need i don't need to
understand the the how to
it's simply as soon as i understand it's
there the how-to will take care of
itself
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it is time for our lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions or comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed
another cool you might remember this
during the lightning round we answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response
but not really we just monitor on a bit
until we find something that is
uh tweetable podcast sean puts these
minimal maxims in the show notes so we
can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like to do that
oh by the way you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place now
it's called minimalmaxims.com ryan we
have a
question from jennifer are there types
of bodywork
that address the body slash mind
connection together
or are there types of psychotherapy that
address the mind slash
body connection and tandem bodies hold
memories in movements
and in holding patterns and sitting on a
couch and talking doesn't address that
fascinating question what are your
thoughts um so yes there are
a lot of body work that we can do and i
believe we need to do
breath work is my number one go-to to
help us
do two things first and foremost drop
into our body to learn how to be
consciously embodied many are like
myself very disconnected from our
physical body
not attuned to its signals may not even
be aware of those emotions happening
everything i'm talking about
for a very long time for me was lost on
me because i felt very flat
if i wasn't feeling anxious i wasn't
really feeling much of anything
so for me it really meant cultivating
that conscious
awareness of my body so breath work
again use like utilizing our breath as
our focal point for our attention helps
us drop into our body
and then of course we can begin to
intentionally
breathe in different patterns to help
regulate our body
because most of us need to do bodywork
as part of our healing journey because
we're living in a very dysregulated body
particularly around our nervous system
so the final part of that answer
is i'm hopeful and the reason why i talk
about holistic psychology and the need
for the field to evolve is my hope that
there comes a time in the very near
future where all practitioners
are working with the body in mind i
think a large reason why myself and
so many of my clients were so
disempowered for so long is because
we haven't been talking about the body
in the mental health field we've only
been talking really about the mind and
i think it's all becoming very clear to
a lot of us that that's only part of the
story so my hope
is that practitioners everywhere will
start to to learn
some new body work modalities to help us
heal
our very dysregulated systems yeah and
you talk about
your breath work in the book and the i
think that
if you don't understand the the power
because it almost sounds cliche of
course i breathe every day i breathe
every minute of every day have you done
breath work yourself
oh yeah yeah and and the wim hall stuff
is crazy
we actually had wim hof on our we did a
youtube video with him put a link to
that in the show notes
uh sean if you don't mind uh but we we
did it
as soon as if i don't do it for a few
days and i go back to it you instantly
realize like how powerful
the breath is now it doesn't have to be
something as extreme
it's not even really extreme what he
does but like it is extreme relative to
my normal
breathing which is tends to be shallow
and not very focused and
i i my wife often like looks at me she's
like
breathe like what are you doing and it's
like oh yeah i'm not breathing but
but i am but i'm just not breathing
effectively or
i'm not getting the amount of oxygen but
you do some wim hof just don't do it
while you're driving you might pass out
right you you do that type of breath
work but then there's obviously a bunch
of other modalities
that that you can embark on i've got a
quick answer for
our show notes here understanding is the
only road that leads to lasting
change so if i were to expand on that i
would say to change the how must follow
the why
so action is fine but if we just
randomly take aimless action you're not
going to get anywhere again if i had
left my my apartment this morning and
i'm just going to
find somewhere to go uh and you know
what i'm going to take a ton of action
i'll start running in a direction i
might be running in the wrong
direction uh in terms of i'm not going
to arrive where i want to arrive so
understanding first that leads to the
action then the action becomes
you know once you understand like okay
breath work will help me
then you can find the modality that
works best for you
yeah i think maybe the best way to sum
that up is like when you're on a journey
you've got where you are you've got
where you're going
and then you have the how you're going
to get there and it's important to have
that balance between
those those things um the breathing
i just want to encourage our listeners
who have
not tried any breath work it is an
instant energy shift
so i'm sure you could find some stuff on
youtube real easily just you know five
minute breathing exercise i did this
like 45 minute class one time and i
thought it was outer space like it was
unbelievable but it was incredibly
empowering
if you have two minutes do you try the
wim hof just check out the video we did
with him or
any of his other videos yeah and you
want to dive deeper of course you can
check out uh how to do the work
there's a lot more in terms of um
bodywork beyond just breath work as well
yeah absolutely
my pithy answer is this uh this is an
oldie but a goodie the mind and body are
separate
but both are standing in the same room
so
you know the couch the therapy on its
own yeah i agree that's probably
not gonna solve the problem taking
action without knowing what you're
taking
action towards that's not going to solve
the problem you have to again find that
balance between where you are
where you're going and how you're going
to get there
yeah i mean maybe i would look at at the
the mind and body
being they mean your mind is part of
your body right
but the it's we do we tend to separate
it especially in our society our culture
we treat it as though
they're standing in separate corners of
the room even right yeah right so
it's like well i got my mind over here
my body over here and there's no overlap
whatsoever it's like well no of course
my
my mind is part of my brain you know or
whatever but it's also
it's part of me it's all it's all
tangled together
yeah and if you're changing one you're
changing the other yeah
i think it's important to also honor the
uniqueness in each of us because a lot
of us do
look outside right we run around in
circles based on what everyone else is
doing
everyone else has worked for what
everyone else
so i think in the process of this
conversation it's also being attuned to
what is working for my body what is
working for my mind
what works for me and that's why i was
always really hesitant
around in the field this idea of a one
size model a one size gold standard cbt
working for everyone
i just never really felt we all fit into
a basket like that so same applies here
and i still see a lot of us even looking
to people like myself
nicole what do you do day in and day out
so i can just follow what you do
absolutely not you're not in my body my
body might react completely different
to the things that i'm doing than to
what you were doing so
the caveat here is finding that place
within
finding and that's why i you know
created the self-healer's hashtag in and
of itself to focus on the self what does
work for me
and to empower us all as individuals to
find that pathway and not
outsource because i've seen that that's
another way we run around in circles
based on because now we have a million
people online
sharing their opinions so we have a
million protocols we could begin
tomorrow if we so choose though
we're quite unique yeah it's it's and by
the way
following that recipe is not going to
get you the same results because
there are a whole bunch of
unquantifiable as well
even if you nicole followed your recipe
you wouldn't get the same results
because there are a lot of
other intricacies and you know it's the
sort of butterfly effect of all the
relationships and
and acculturation that's gone on in your
life that has led you to where you are
part of that has to do with the recipe
the step-by-step thing
but if it's not if that you followed and
this wouldn't work for you of course
it's not going to work for someone
else exactly the same way that it works
for you
and so that but that's the beauty of a
recipe you can tweeze out the
ingredients that do work
and create your own you can adjust for
taste so to speak yeah there's something
about that
the couch work too because i have done a
lot of therapy in my life
and it's almost like they can help you
put together a recipe to try out
um but yeah going and seeing a therapist
without doing the work
that's involved after you talk to your
therapist even if it's just
a perspective shift i mean the best
therapists that i've had they just help
me look at something a little bit
differently
and then when i ruminate i focus on that
perspective that they helped
helped me get so um yeah couch work is
great but it has to be coupled with
with action and i think the best couch
work so to speak
will sort of force action in a way
because if it
delivers that understanding to you for
example if you read how to do the work
and
from that you get a deeper more profound
understanding
then the how-to begins to appear before
you you begin to understand okay there
are some tips and things
in here but i once i have that
understanding i know what direction
in which i need to walk to move ahead we
got a bunch more to talk about but first
ryan what do you got for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
check them out hi joshua this is molly
from michigan what we do
is we will buy things
on trips that aren't stereotypical
souvenirs they're more
everyday type items so for example on
our honeymoon in ireland
my husband bought a tweed jacket
and it's great he wears it in the fall
he wears it
in the spring it's the perfect jacket
for
that time when it's just a little too
cold for sport coats
but it's too warm for a big pea coat a
big puffy down coat
and it really fits a spot
in his wardrobe
and he was able to buy something there
that's unusual not the kind of thing
you would get here and then every time
he wears it
he reminds him of our trip but it's
not just from jochke hi
this is xena calling from the channel
islands in the uk
i just wanted to give some advice to
anyone who might be planning their
wedding
i'm currently in the stages of planning
ours
and as you probably know it can get
expensive very quickly
so we're looking at different ways that
we can reduce the costs
and we were discussing our wedding rings
and basically
i have some old jewelry
that i no longer wear and i was looking
at how i could let these go
so an idea that we had was to trade in
this old jewelry i no longer wear
to reduce the cost of wedding rings and
we managed to
reduce it by about 20 pounds by trading
in this
old jewelry which i know it doesn't
sound like a lot in the grand scheme of
things
but every little helps and it was a
really nice way of
letting go of some old jewelry
and putting the money towards something
meaningful towards our future
all right y'all thanks again to nicole
for joining us today we have a bunch
more surprise questions for her this
week on
the minimalist private podcast but in
the meantime make sure you check out her
book it's called
how to do the work love the subtitle
ryan recognize your patterns
heal from your past and create yourself
you can also find her online she's a
brand new website the holistic
psychologist dot com
follow her on instagram as well we'll
put a link to her instagram and her
youtube channel
on our podcast show notes because she
has a thriving community
in both places on instagram and on
youtube
the holistic psychologist and real quick
for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalist ryan
it is time for our annual performance
review
all right i quit
you remember those all right so for
those of you who aren't familiar with
annual performance reviews
uh you know in some corporations
virtually every corporation yeah they
have you do an annual performance review
so
when you're on the bottom run it's
really easy because you just have to do
it for yourself
you have to like reflect on how your
year was and then you go see your bus
and then your boss tells you
you know they reflect with you agree
with you or disagree with you whatever
when you're managing 150 retail stores
and you're managing those managers
there's a lot of performance reviews
yeah and that was probably like the you
might have liked it because there was a
lot of writing involved
that was the kind of writing that was
the writing i had to do didn't get to do
yeah the the but what we're asking for
today is we don't do this you hear most
people they do a podcast or
make sure you like and subscribe you're
never gonna hear me tell you to like and
subscribe
to anything subscribe if you want yeah
if you don't want to then don't
but one thing that does help us we tend
to ask for this once a year that's why
i'm calling our annual performance
review
you can rate us on apple podcasts and
you can leave us whatever you think a
fair rating is and also write a review
that does help us in the algorithms it
helps us reach
more people so we don't ask for this
every episode like everyone else does
every other podcast you listen to
they give you 14 different
advertisements and then they also ask
you to go out of your way to rate them
every single episode
we don't do it we do that once or twice
a year we'll ask you hey in fact last
year i don't know we did it at all last
year so
if you haven't rated us on apple podcast
even if you don't listen to this on
apple podcast that's okay
head on over to apple podcast give us a
a star rating however many stars you
think
we're worth if it's five stars that's
wonderful we just want an honest rating
yes and and then leave us a review what
do you love about the show because if
you think other people will get value
from the show
then please that's one of the best ways
to support us so give us our annual
performance review
applepodcast.com the minimalist we'll
put a link to that in
the show notes as well real quick rhyme
for our added value segment
this week one of my favorite albums from
a couple years ago is this gal she
goes by the name the japanese house
that's like her stage name
she had a phenomenal album a few years
ago i think it was my my top album when
i do the in
year-end review and she just put out a
new ep the ep is called
chewing cotton wool and it's sort of
ethereal but it's also
ruminative contemplative music
is maybe the way i would describe it
let's listen to the title track from
that new ep it's called chewing cotton
wool
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like
how do i break the habit of rumination
how do i alleviate my anxiety
how do you make peace with the past how
does
one stop self-sabotaging and
what's the 90-second rule plus three
ways to set boundaries and a million
more questions for nicole
and if you want to hear all that join
the minimalist private podcast this week
that's right visit theminimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal links so that our private
podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram
at the minimalist come to one of our
live podcast shows visit
the minimalists.com troy to find a city
near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to podcast
at theminimalists.com you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com
the minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
any new minimalist
writings that we write for free right
there in your inbox you know what we
won't send you
spam you send me
cans of spam all the time usps can i
admit something
no i'm going to admit it anyway do it i
freaking love spam
i love me some fried spinach i haven't
had it in so long but it's like
fried bologna but better yeah but you
don't want to be forced to eat it is the
thing exactly
and that's what email inbox spam is
it's it's taking something that you
might enjoy and it's cramming it down
your throat we're never gonna do that to
you so sign up only if you think you'll
get value by the way if you do join us
on our private podcast this week it's
cheaper than a cup of coffee
and it keeps our show 100 advertisement
free thank you so much to
our patreon supporters who support us
over there if you leave here today with
just one message
let it be this love people and use
things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening yo
we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it